[Music]
on this sunday night crossing into
canada
during covet 19. how many people have
tried to get in
despite the border closure obviously
here in canada it's much better
than it is in the states and closing the
loopholes
the grief in an ontario community they
were the type of people we should all
strive to be
after a gunman kills four members of the
same family
plus the first election in canada during
covent and the votes are coming in
early plus why scientists are excited
about two black holes
merging
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin tonight with some surprising
figures from the canada border services
agency
thousands of foreign nationals have
tried to get into this country
for non-essential reasons despite those
restrictions
the canada u.s border has been closed to
most travelers since mid-march
and as michael couture reports many
believe it should stay that way
into next year susan connor and her
husband gary burnett have been trying to
carve out a modest living
by selling art in ottawa's historic
byward market
this year has been difficult with the
pandemic preventing tourists
from coming to canada our sales are down
close to 40 percent and i think we're
fortunate
that that's all it is they've seen less
foot traffic pass by their stall this
summer because of the partial closure of
the canada-us border
however it seems some people have tested
the system
according to statistics from the canada
border services agency
between march 22nd and september 2nd
more than
18 thousand four nationals were denied
entry into canada
because their trips were deemed
discretionary
of those people a little more than 16
000 were us citizens and more than
2 300 were citizens of other countries
arriving from the u.s also over that
same period 448
travelers tried to get into canada by
air arriving from other foreign
countries
in an interview with global news earlier
this week the leading american expert on
infectious diseases
questioned the efficacy of the border
closure
you know sometimes it does have a
positive effect of keeping the lid on
things
but sometimes you know it just doesn't
make that much difference so there is
always this argument as to the benefit
or not of doing that five americans with
alaska license plates have been fined
for violating the quarantine act in
british columbia
they were supposed to take the most
direct route back to washington state
but instead
went sightseeing in vancouver four days
after entering canada
some canadian doctors believe with a
high rate of infection in the u.s
it's better not to reopen the border yet
when we open the board as a question
of considering many many factors i do
think that at some point in 2021 it
could happen
but i do think it will be in the
post-vaccine era
that could be a year away but burnett
doesn't mind
even if his business continues to suffer
if you don't have health
what do you have a simple mantra in such
a complicated time
mike lacrouter global news ottawa
in tourist hot spot banff alberta rcmp
received more than 240 complaints of
cars with u.s plates this summer
even with the unwelcome guests and an
influx of local tourism in the area
the loss of foreign tourism has taken a
major toll on the town
and as jamie dahl reports the industry
is bracing for more tough days
ahead so pull it up as high as you can
originally from australia this couple is
ending their three-year stint living in
canada exploring the rockies
we were hiking yesterday i felt like we
had to park to ourselves
hearing an australian accent in banff as
common as the peaks towering above
but not as much these days coven 19
travel restrictions hitting the tourism
industry harder than any crisis before
a deep uncertainty hovers in the air
here as businesses look forward to the
season ahead
we're all suffering it's not easy we've
been working on hiring all summer long
and things are looking okay
we are going to be using a bit less
staff because we are planning maybe not
as many snow school programs this winter
not as many other things
our anxiety levels are rising the
radiant lounge and stage
just opened its doors for the first time
in june the owners admit
some days have been steady others dead
quiet the fall time used to be when a
lot of international travelers would
come
a lot of the more mature travelers would
take the bus trips in september when it
was a little cooler it was
a little quieter and we're definitely
not going to have those this year
so the fear is that we might be a little
bit of a ghost town
vehicle numbers into the town side of
banff were down 69 percent in july
24 in august compared to the summer of
2019.
when we look at our hotel occupancy
numbers july occupancy was
about 46 percent um so typically it's 90
plus percent
uh in july and august and so that was
obviously
um decreased quite a bit from last year
it has been a hard summer compared to
previous summers
but we're going to move forward larch
season is coming
biking is still awesome the mosquitoes
are all dying
a plus for these travelers soaking up as
much as they can
before going into a long quarantine when
they return home
jamie doll global news bamf alberta
there are more covet cases being linked
to large gatherings in ontario this time
it's a wedding health officials say 11
people who tested positive can be traced
back to events tied
to one wedding the events took place in
toronto markham
and the town of white church stouffville
last weekend
the health authority is working with the
family to notify all attendees about the
potential exposure
a tightly knit community in oshawa is
reeling for the four
family members shot dead inside their
home on friday morning
the mother of the family fifth-year-old
loretta traynor is the only survivor
the accused gunman is her brother her
husband chris trainer taught at the
local high school
their three children bradley adelaide
and 11 year old joseph traynor were also
killed tonight as morgan campbell
reports friends young and old
are trying to come to terms with the
tragedy
friends say chris and loretta traynor
were high school sweethearts who
dedicated their adult lives
to education and giving back to their
community
they were incredible people and they had
a beautiful family
and if you knew them you loved them and
you can't not
respect who they were for this entire
community
a memorial grows outside of their oshawa
ontario home this is where police say
the family
was gunned down by loretta's brother
officers believe mitchell lapa
drove from winnipeg and entered the
trainer's home
uninvited early friday morning with a
long gun
killing chris and three of their
children and wounding loretta
sources tell global news the shooting
may have been
over a family will when i've met them
they've been
super sweet family probably sweet as
i've met in a long time
chris was a teacher at monsignor paul
dwyer catholic high school
where tributes have been placed outside
the main doors
loretta was a teacher at saint teresa
catholic school
flags there have been lowered in her
memory
i don't think our community has ever
faced anything like this in the history
of our great city
i can't find the right words we're just
absolutely devastated
the durham catholic district school
board has offered support to students
and their families
a measure to help people heal from such
a tragedy
when we're in something together that
there are emotions
interconnect however i would also say
it's okay
to to have some solitude and some
self-reflection
some time for self-care as well and you
really want to balance those two
meanwhile more than 71 thousand dollars
has been raised in support of the
surviving members
of the trainer family they were the type
of people we should all strive to be
if you were any less of a person than
what that family modeled
you should be striving for more in your
life police haven't released any updates
regarding the investigation but remain
here
on scene in oshawa there's also a police
presence
in winnipeg outside of the apartment
building where it's believed
lapa lived robin morgan campbell
in oshawa jacob blake spoke from his
hospital bed today sending a message to
his supporters that life can change
in an instant blake is paralyzed from
the waist down
and is recovering in hospital after
being shot seven
times in the back by a police officer in
wisconsin
your life and not only just your life
your legs something that you need to
move around and move forward and life
can be taken from you like
this man the shooting has triggered a
wave of violent and deadly protests
against police brutality and systemic
racism in america
similar protests were sparked in the
wake of the death of george floyd while
in police custody
nearly three months earlier
america's first black vice presidential
candidate is condemning the president
and his attorney general
for denying racial problems exist within
the u.s justice system
kamala harris says two systems exist and
points to the demonstrations that have
erupted in the wake of black people
being shot by white officers
the president says protesters not police
are the problem
here's jennifer johnson with less than
two months to go before election day
democratic vice presidential candidate
kamala harris has come out swinging
blasting u.s president donald trump and
his attorney general
for denying their systemic racism in
america's legal system
in an interview with cnn i think that
donald trump
and bill barr are spending full time
in a different reality we do
have two systems of justice in america
harris the first woman of color
to be a vice presidential candidate is
on the attack
after statements from both the president
and william barr last week
i don't think they're two justice
systems the fact of the matter is very
rare for an unarmed
african-american to be shot by a white
police officer president trump refused
to address the issue during a visit to
kenosha wisconsin
following the police involved shooting
of jacob blake we should talk about the
kind of violence that we've seen in
portland and here and other places and
that's what this is
all about after a series of police
involved shootings of black americans
cities across the united states have
erupted in protests
100 straight nights in portland oregon
where molotov cocktails were thrown
saturday
police responded with tear gas i
understand that they're tired
but at the same time we're tired of you
killing black people
the protests and now counter protests in
every u.s state were sparked by the
death of george floyd in minneapolis
who died after a white police officer
knelt on his neck for almost nine
minutes
there's no question that we have seen an
unacceptable incident for generations of
unarmed black men being killed
nobody can deny that harris says the
facts
are black americans are arrested and
prosecuted far more for the same
offenses than white americans
a recent abc news washington post poll
shows just how divided the country is
nearly 9 in 10 black americans are not
confident
police treat blacks and whites equally
while a majority of white americans feel
there is
equal treatment jennifer johnson global
news
washington a dangerous rescue operation
is underway in california as the
military and fire crews battle
an explosive wildfire north of l.a
the creek fire's roaring flames scorched
a national force near fresno on saturday
terrifying footage shows campers trying
to escape by car
over 200 people have been airlifted to
safety with dozens
hospitalized the fire is zero percent
contained
and one of 22 raging across california
during a record heat wave japan is
bracing for typhoon hyshen's full brunt
with winds forecast to reach 252
kilometers an hour
high waves are lashing the coast and
already strong winds have knocked out
power for thousands of homes
officials warn the typhoon may bring
record rainfall
and are recommending evacuations for the
area
at least one police officer has been
killed in a terror attack in tunisia
the government says suspected islamic
militants rammed a vehicle
into a checkpoint and then attacked the
officers with knives
one died another was injured three of
the attackers were killed in a shootout
with security forces it's unclear at
this point if the attackers were tied to
a particular extremist group
coming up the first election in canada
during covid
many canadians are spending the labor
day weekend enjoying the last of the
summer break
but in new brunswick tens of thousands
of people spent at least part of the
holiday
fulfilling their civic duty new
brunswickers turned out in unusually
high numbers for advanced polling
as ross lord explains many were eager to
avoid election day lineups
because of the pandemic before they
conduct canada's first
general election of the pandemic new
brunswickers are taking advantage of the
option
of voting early i thought i better get
here before there's too big a lineup
advance polls like this one and roth say
report big increases in turnout compared
to the previous election two years ago i
usually actually come to the advanced
polls because i'm a working mom so it's
actually kind of easier but i'm
surprised
how many people are at this time so
early we are seeing lineups which i
would say
is unusual for the event the first day
of advanced voting
elections mb is encouraging people to
avoid even longer lineups on election
day
by voting early or by mail-in ballot
organizers hope by limiting large
clusters of voters
that help prevent the spread of covert
19. i suspect the
pandemic has something to do with it
including the reason i'm here
not going to be available on one of the
other
times it's a nice day and and avoid the
crowd
polls suggest the progressive
conservatives under former irving oil
executive blaine higgs
might turn their shaky minority
government into a more comfortable
majority
for those wondering if canadians will
take an interest in voting during the
pandemic
the early indications from new brunswick
are encouraging
so it is safe to vote especially given
the measures that
elections new brunswick has put in place
around social distancing around face
masks
around hand sanitizers the second chance
to vote early comes on tuesday
the new brunswick general election is
less than a week later
on september 14th ross lord global news
there's a new baby announcement coming
from the west coast the pacific whale
watch association has confirmed orca
j-35
better known as telequa has given birth
the new calf was spotted saturday near
the san juan islands
two years ago talaqua caught the world's
attention when she refused to let go of
her dead calf for 17 days
it was a heartbreaking image
still ahead three canadians are making
grand slam history
canada could be on the cusp of a new
golden era of tennis
three rising stars made history by
advancing into round four of the same
grand slam
the three men felix o'jay aliasim
posbasil and dennis shapilov have all
advanced into the fourth round of the
u.s open that's never happened at a
grand slam before
but the three have another one to beat
no canadian man has
ever reached the competition's
quarterfinals
up next the mega excitement over a
mid-sized discovery in deep space
an austrian man had to focus on keeping
his cool while spending
two and a half hours in a box filled
with ice
wearing only swim trunks joseph kerbel
was surrounded by more than
200 kilograms of ice cubes he endured
the wave of pain by focusing on positive
emotions
his goal was to beat his own record
which he did by 30 minutes
an international team of researchers
including canadian scientists
has made a major space discovery they've
detected a signal from what may be the
most
massive black hole merger ever observed
the collision created a new size of
black hole one that's never been seen
before
and as eric sorensen explains the
discovery is being touted as a cosmic
holy grail it happened so far away in
space that its detection at all
surprised scientists the merging of two
black holes
more than five billion light years away
black holes were once stars that went
supernova
then collapsed into something so dense
that nothing not even light can escape
when they collide and merge
gravitational waves burst out into space
the waves themselves only discovered a
few years ago
gravitational waves we're just now
really starting to see
what's out there in the darkness of deep
space
jess mchiver of the university of
british columbia is part of the
international team
plugged into enormous wave detectors
kilometers long
one in europe two in the united states
the waves registered 16 months ago and
now confirmed
are the most distant events ever
detected directly from earth
this is the shortest event that's ever
been registered in our gravitational
wave detectors which means it looks
quite a lot
like glitches little blips of noise that
you might see
in the detector data stream the creation
of a mid-sized black hole
fills an important gap in understanding
the forces at work in the universe
it truly is incomprehensible there is
nothing humanity
can do that even remotely approaches
the amount of energy we're talking about
here the earth is tiny compared with our
sun
the sun also dwarfs the size of a black
hole formed by a collapsed star
but even that small black hole can have
70 times the mass of the sun
and there are enormous black holes
millions or billions of times more
massive than the sun
what scientists have now discovered is
being called the missing link
this mid-sized black hole formed from
the two smaller black holes
it's 142 times the mass of our sun
black holes that merge suggest one way
massive black holes may form
and all of them are believed to play a
role in the evolution of the galaxies
by learning about the most massive stars
and using black holes to tell us about
them
we are learning about the origin of us
gravitational wave detectors on earth
are opening the skies to new discoveries
and new understanding so it's sort of
akin to
inventing the telescope for the first
time where we're not necessarily
entirely sure
what we're going to see so it's very
very exciting this is
yet another piece of the jigsaw puzzle
that talks about the evolution of the
universe as a whole
not just stars and galaxies but planets
and life as well
gravitational waves suggest einstein was
right that time and space can bend
and new tools and observations around
black holes
continue to turn his theories into
scientific reality
erik sorensen global news toronto and
that is global national for this sunday
i'm robin gill
tonight your canada is ula haktak in the
northwest territories
thank you for sharing your time with us
this long weekend we hope to see you
back here tomorrow
have a great night
[Music]